okay I'll be honest I saw the clips too
but
they have they have a great this is
great conversation they do the podcast
and there's two friends talking and like
two friends who've had incredible
success in their careers reflecting on
their success reflecting on therapy
reflecting on like how they see them
they're at different Generations too
which is kind of cool like yo that was
the first one that's [__] awesome
that was the first time Drake's been
called old yeah you've been thinking it
yeah he's probably been thinking it you
know which is probably the reason for a
lot of his moves lately but when Yadi
said that to him he had that he had to
ask like yo how old are you yeah yeah he
was like I was 25 and he was like he had
to think about that [__] like yeah he
said I think he's only 25 25. there's a
moment and I think it was when yachty
called them all where Drake's talking
and then he he says I'm like I'm 36 now
whatever yeah goes damn that's old and
Drake stops mid-sentence and goes
and he was like oh [__] yo Drake welcome
to my world my boy
that's gonna be you for the rest of your
career you are the Elder Statesman now
you are the OG he says the same [__] I
say when they kill when people call me
oh I'm like you could get old just wait
I can't wait till you get old it's the
truth it was so funny because Drake
started going like I'm still being shape
you know what I'm saying
I I'm like oh [__] that [__] hurt him
like that [__] cut him deep yeah but
yeah I enjoy I mean I enjoyed the clips
of the combo today how old is Drake 35 I
think that's when you start to realize
your mortality a little bit he's got a
kid his kid is now older and he's like
having like a real relationship with him
yeah yeah once you're on the once you
pass that that 35 is really the 40
threshold
you know what I mean like really 50 and
rap He is bro what you mean because he's
been around the past decade oh yeah like
Drake has given us so much music like
there's nothing like when Drake's uh
well Envy was saying the other day that
he wants Drake to drop One More album
before he retires like a rap album I'm
like what more can he do no he can't do
anything
he's done everything every genre of
music like outsold everyone yeah but
this is the the stuff that I think that
he can do because I don't think that
we've had this type of intimacy with
Drake so it's like Drake has been super
vulnerable in the lyrics but still
contained to a song right yeah yeah this
was really cool to see somebody say yo
are you older than him react and keep
that [__] in
show I think Drake has a lot that he
wants to say that for whatever whatever
reason he's not able to convey it
through music because he's been doing
this lately you know he did this
interview with Yadi then a couple who
did it with Caleb Presley as well that's
who that was when he was sitting outside
yes no was it outside
oh no he did care Presley but he did
another one but he was just like sitting
outside somewhere like oh that was like
a live stream or something yeah he's
been doing this more and more yeah
because before that was just the Rap
Radar yeah but it's good reflect like I
love to see it I love to see people and
maybe there's some self-interest in it
because you're looking at people who
have had success and and if they're
being reflective on their success and
how it's changed their life and how it's
changed their relationships and all
these things it's cool to know what
they're thinking in their positions
right because you're always aspiring to
be there but you also want to know what
the problems are when you go there so
you know selfishly was really cool but
you don't get to see Uber successful
people reflect that often if maybe you
get an interview on The Breakfast Club
where you can like really open them up
right right but like oftentimes how
often do we see it like I like it but I
still think it's too young for them to
be reflecting like even when billboard
did that list when billboard had like
Kendrick Lamar as the number two
greatest rapper of all time and I think
Drake was like top 10 I'm like it was
too early for all that it's too early to
have the Drakes and the Kendricks in the
top tens of all he was 50 in rabies
yeah but I I think when it comes to
greatest of all time you have to do at
least 15 to 20 years but that's business
what I'm saying is I want to know about
how how life experience has impacted you
to me that's the most interesting he
said an interesting thing when he was
talking about the therapy [__] and he's
basically talking about like how he got
big titties
and it's cool to see like that there was
put it in in a way for her to completely
relate you think that the girl this bad
girl that you with got the big titties
everybody's looking at her no the reason
Drake is your ass in the room the reason
Drake sounds crazy repeating that is
because when your therapist tells you
things therapist is telling you things
he's telling you things or she is
telling you things for you to understand
confidence you know what I mean so
whatever that reference that uh his
therapist told him was for him yeah it
sounds crazy to us but she sat with him
enough to know how to talk to him and to
connect with him and to get him to
understand what it is that she's saying
so to us when he's repeating like you
know that's why I can relate to women
with big titties and you know I feel
like a pair of titties in the room it
sounds crazy to us but that is a
composition that he says but you go to
therapy but I do love this idea that
like she tried to communicate in a bunch
of other ways and then he probably
didn't get it she was fine it's titties
bro you guys
I go to therapy you go to therapy we
understand that therapy talk I get what
that the therapist connected with him on
a level and now he's trying to relate to
it to people but they're probably
looking at him like what the [__] is he
talking about yeah you're talking about
titties with his therapist yes yeah a
good therapist should meet you where you
are yeah yeah to take you wish he or she
needs you to go yeah I think so anyway
it was just cool it's a rare
conversation say what no I need a better
therapist
money you can pay for a great therapy
oh so Charlotte you want me bro what son
you got you got to bleach a little bit
boy men have titties now too by the way
I just want you to know that oh man what
do you mean men have changed yeah of
course you can get you a titty you can
get you a titty dick combo if you want
it at least you can yeah yeah I'm glad
that you acknowledge that finally no I'm
just letting Alex no that's there's
other stuff on the menu
he works at Cheesecake Factory look at
his
[Laughter]
looks because y'all have aged and got
younger and I don't know what it is this
is a secret I don't know
your emotions I've been hearing that
though you know what's so crazy I've
been hearing that a lot and it's wild
I'm like [__] you got Botox stop it I
never got Botox
cat